[Música]
actualizaciones de la economía con
daniela blandón aquí en directo américa
a daniela un saludo nuevamente para
usted y otra vez empezamos con los
emiratos árabes unidos- y se ve difícil
que podemos sustituir a rusia en el
mercado petrolero hola angela nuevamente
pues es y rusia- produce alrededor de 11
millones de barriles por día de petróleo
y de ese total más del 70 por ciento lo
exporta a otros países por eso el
ministro de energía de emiratos árabes
unidos dijo en un evento de la industria
que su país está dispuesto sigue
aumentar la producción pero bajo los
parámetros que decida la opep más y
recordemos que allí está rusia pero
también dirigió un ácido comentario a
los participantes de la competición que
fue la cumbre climática del año pasado
where everyone says estamos en un
entorno en el que todos dicen aumenta su
producción traiga más recursos
pero si vamos a las instituciones
financieras todavía dudan en financiar
muchos proyectos de petróleo y gas en el
mundo oil and gas básicamente están
diciendo necesitamos que incrementen la
producción sólo por unos pocos años y
después de eso muchas gracias youtube en
crisis de production for all y flyers en
adaptar data en que veremos como si
fuera un grifo se abre y luego se puede
cerrar
y vamos a continuar daniela con más de
rusia los rusos luchan contra una
inflación altísima mientras que el
kremlin dice que es apoyado por la
población
'los por lo menos parece que ese apoyo a
vladimir putin está persistiendo según
una encuesta del centro de investigación
de la opinión pública de rusia que dice
que el presidente ruso tiene un índice
de confianza del 80 por ciento y como se
explica este apoyo la respuesta está en
el siguiente informe
jubilado alexander paga sus compras y en
cuanto a los precios nada es igual que
antes
lo que me sorprendió fue el precio de
estos pimentones 277 rublos el kilo es
una locura de precio para las verduras
desde la invasión de ucrania y la caída
del rublo la inflación se ha disparado
así que como todos los rusos alexander
tiene que adaptarse
el jugo de frutas por ejemplo no puedo
llevarme el que quiero tengo que buscar
artículos con descuentos
para ayudarle a poner las cosas en
perspectiva puede contar con los canales
de televisión rusos
no ves el mundo entero es deficitarios
no sólo aquí suben los precios
circulaciones de sus a veces alexander
siente que no se le dice todo
me digo a mí mismo que probablemente sea
cierto
porque parece ser cierto pero al mismo
tiempo no lo parece en absoluto cátedra
de tesis cuando escucha ciertos mensajes
de propaganda realmente duda
en documentos del equipo del cerca
grises pero te ofrece
un ataque de ucrania crimea lo dudo
saben que habría sido una guerra abierta
con rusia
sin embargo apoya a su país ya su
presidente
coalición acusar a putin de todos los
males es como acusar a stalin son justos
este es el curso político e histórico el
que les obligó a tomar esas decisiones
no tenían otra opción primero curso
ya recién por favor comprendan soy ruso
y no veo cómo puedo no apoyar a mi país
puedo ser crítico o me puede disgustar
pero en tal situación debo apoyarlo
es como una esposa con una buena esposa
puede pensar que su marido tiene razón o
puede que no pero en cualquier caso
tiene que estar a su lado para recargar
sus municiones
alexander tiene esta actitud ahora vital
para los rusos la resignación
daniela que otras noticias económicas
esperamos para hoy pues de angela inicia
este lunes la asamblea de líderes del
banco interamericano de desarrrollo una
de las principales fuentes de
financiamiento de la región el evento
que estaba programado para punta del
este en uruguay irá hasta el viernes
primero de abril y se hará de manera
virtual por la pandemia este año la
cumbre estará centrada en la
recuperación y el crecimiento tras la
crisis sanitaria también se espera que
el gobierno de eeuu presente su proyecto
de presupuesto para el año fiscal 2000
22 que inicia el primero de octubre
según un adelanto de la oficina del
presupuesto se propondrá introducir un
impuesto mínimo del 20 por ciento a los
estadounidenses con fortunas de más de
100 millones de dólares uno de los
objetivos es reducir el déficit
presupuestario en un billón de dólares
en la próxima década y sólo para este
año se espera que el déficit caiga a la
mitad desde los 28 billones del año
pasado y cuáles son los indicadores que
ya nos llegan de la jornada en las
acciones asiáticas cerraron al alza
después de que shanghái entrará en un
semi bloqueo de nueve días por un nuevo
brote 19 las bolsas europeas a media
marcha operan con buenas ganancias a
medida que los precios del petróleo caen
el día de hoy muy bien daniela eso es
todo por hoy y mañana seguimos con más
claro decían la vamos ahora directo o
parís